we only have a little time left but
first i am so
happy to announce our first show
baby congrats to our
writer christina and her husband danny
on the birth of
martha millie nem check
martha milly nem check welcome to the
world
buckle up it's gonna be a bumpy ride but
i promise
you're gonna love it and we're gonna
love you right back
so hi bffs how you doing
we we have a little surprise in our
audience phil
how you doing were you at last night's
emmys
hi drew yes i was
we've got an emmy has man oh thank you
phil for coming here how was it
how was it it was incredible it was such
a fun show yeah
it was i was stationed at hugh jackman
so that was crazy
i just have to say your outfit you are
giving it this
is a tux 2020 style i am so
in thank you for coming thank you we
loved you guys last
night okay erin i heard there's another
question from aaron erin where are you
hello erin hi yes i read your
autobiography when i was in high school
and i have a question for you which i
absolutely loved it
how have your life experiences shaped
the mother you are today
oh my god entirely first of all my
parents kind of gave me a blueprint of
everything not to do checkity check
then i really took all my life
experiences and instead of
speaking negatively about them to my
children because i don't feel that way i
love and embrace all
of them but it has turned me into a
mother who really cares
about the pillars of appropriateness and
how to be safe and stay young as long as
possible so
really all of our life lessons should be
lessons to us
and our kids not our weaknesses but our
strengths
thank you for asking that question aaron
and to everyone at home
thank you so much for joining us
[Music]
you